because
it if you look at it because I was
sitting there and you were talking if
you look at it and you listen to what
you're saying and how you say you
believe this way you went one place and
you changed your whole belief system
it's like how can you be this and then
go somewhere instantly change it because
of you saying that sitting in this seat
right here
it gave other people a perspective that
you weren't strong enough in your faith
to go to another place to where it was a
different environment different Religion
different everything to be able to stay
strong in that as soon as you got there
or not as soon as you got there but when
you got there it changed it flipped so
from what you from the words that came
out of your mouth it gave other people a
perspective and that's what they were
saying to you it wasn't that they were
saying anything we're on a podcast with
lots of people talking you guys didn't
even let me finish you didn't let me no
we didn't let you we did let you finish
yes we did we did let you finish because
that's how it started where I started to
it wasn't because I went to China it was
because I just started reflecting on
life so I'm not saying I I literally
just went to China and my face just but
that's what you said no I didn't yeah
okay but the whole but even even if it
even if okay let's say it how okay okay
okay even if even if even if it happened
over even something else even this way
you're doing right now it's emotional
response to something that you can just
say do you know what I did get emotional
but I [ __ ] up [ __ ] you the haters I'm
a G I'll still stick by what I stand my
faith is not weak I went to China I just
saw a different perspective and I
re-analyzed bam situation finito like I
don't really benefit from it you know
what I mean you do to me it's not really
something I want to talk about but
you've been you don't benefit from
reacting like this and putting something
else if you didn't want to talk about it
you went on another podcast and talked
about it I spoke about it because when
are we walking when we went on Eddie's
show do you know Eddie orchestrated the
whole thing right so we went on the show
we were meant to talk about um I can't
even remember women he said Soraya
wanted to talk about it was that not
true no that's a lie so Sarai was
talking about experience and then Eddie
was like this is good content let's film
and he just said something so obviously
obviously I'll say it with my chest you
don't have to feel like you were rude
and I said it on the show but that's
just is what it is I I'm ready to move
on from it because it is just what it is
I don't personally I don't agree with
that way of conducting I don't care
about thick skin we don't need to be
thick skin I'm sorry we do have I'm
sorry we need to have censorship Because
unless people know what they're going
into we know my sister if we had
censorship then who's the one that's
going to control that because if we have
censorship according to pulse followers
I should be shut down immediately do not
what I'm trying to say is not everyone
is you and exactly
the whole point is if you ain't like me
don't go and talk like you like me don't
go sit against somebody like pumpkin
this is why you'll put on it and I'm not
gonna move on
because you have the problem with modern
women and I'll tell you why because no I
am not because I stand here and people
come for me and that's the strongest
you're cutting me off
if you don't interrupt me then I'll tell
you very very well done to you because
I'll tell you something when you come on
the internet wherever you go you think
you got a voice you stand by it you
don't take it back and get upset because
somebody didn't agree with you I had way
more hate than you I've had a lot more
rejection and a lot more reactions
against me than you have had and I stood
here and the reason why it didn't stick
to me is because I am not weak I stand
in my thoughts I stand in my beliefs I
stand in my truth if you are not a woman
that can speak in her truth do not put
yourself against people that go against
you so many times
okay
because you're talking [ __ ] now you're
talking [ __ ] no because
no it's about it's about the fact
everybody cares about how some people
want yeah
come here Esther you are the Exotic
design about yourself it's not about me
bro you went against somebody like Pearl
and this is about Pearl I won't even
make it about my about myself bro well
came for me the same way in fact I argue
with Paul way more than you do I've been
on the show way more times than you have
I faced Auntie Jenny way more times than
I than you have it wait wait wait wait
wait shut up and listen You'll soon
no but she's not she's not saying that
she's doing it for class she's she's
giving an example that she's been in
your shoes but she's handled it a
different way she's taking it
you've not let me finish because you say
you want to move on if you want to move
on let me finish speaking because I'm
most other than you and I'll most up
until I finish my point and my point
simply is if you are not willing to take
[ __ ] don't go and talk if you're not
willing to stand your ground as a woman
don't go out there and be going for a
fight if you're not ready to fight you
exit the situation straight away if you
want to stay in Fight You Stand Tall and
you fight I'm not afraid to sit here and
argue with this one listen
you had a conversation that didn't go
your way you didn't like what you heard
and now you're labeling people to be
misogynistic racist and this and that
when I've had the same experience on the
podcast you did I've had the same
experience I've had bigger head-to-heads
with both people that you're referring
to and I don't feel the same way because
I understand it's not personal it's not
about race it's about who are you what
do you stand for how much do you respect
yourself and what you think and what you
believe and clearly but how you have
acting even how you're acting right now
it's not very high
I don't need to
because because at the end of the day
you asked about my experience right if
we're going to talk about dinner I
didn't ask about your experience don't
don't bring it about your experience
about mice okay my experiences let's
make a dinner and forget about Esther
let me tell you yeah a powerful strong
woman that respects itself and holds the
truth will sit here and have people
shouting in her ear telling her that she
was not abused for five years because
she didn't report it to the police and
guess what she does she says that will
conversion says you say what you got to
say I know my truth and by the way my
sisters if you need help I'm here for
you it's that simple I don't care about
what these people have to say because in
my opinion they talk [ __ ] because that
truth is not my truth simple simple
nothing more nothing less and instead
you choose to sit here shout and be rude
into the points wait wait do the point
to the point that you're swearing at me
no no I didn't yes you did I didn't
you're like oh that [ __ ] no no no no no
I did that it actually doesn't that God
wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
because you're fighting against the
person that stands on your side listen
be quiet 50 seconds you're still
shouting
you are the problem
it's your embarrassing to be here and
here a sister like you speak to a woman
like me in the way that you have spoken
to me it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing people are sitting here
trying to give you pointers so that you
can survive
I'll give you 30 more seconds can you
finish your point in 30 seconds okay and
then I'll give you 30 seconds to respond
and then we'll be done okay my Point
simply is ladies if you're going to open
your mouth be ready for the consequences
that will come after your words if
you're going somewhere and people are
coming for you and you cannot handle
that and you can feel upset it's because
you are not comfortable with who you are
don't blame it on other people it's
really that simple don't come here cold
Pearl names if you are not the G that
can actually sit there and debate
intellectually without any issues that's
that simple emotional response is
weakness there you go it's okay okay
Esther you have 30 seconds what I have
to say is when I was invited on the show
I didn't know I was coming on Pearl show
Eddie invited me onto a YouTube show I
take accountability because I should
have asked and made sure I clarified
which show I was getting going on I
didn't know I've never seen this type of
show before I would have not opted in I
I wouldn't I don't like aggressive going
back insulting each other I don't that's
I'm a presenter you know it's not good
for my brand I don't I don't do that
type of stuff so it's like when I came
here I was just like wait we're going
against trans people like at times
okay okay okay okay
30 seconds time's up your time's up as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible